it is so great to be joined today by
Miguel Robles Duran who is associate
professor of urbanism at the new school
Parsons School of Design and co-founder
of the nonprofit cooperative for socio
spatial development cohabitation
strategies based in New York City and in
Rotterdam Miguel it's so great to talk
to you we've been analyzing the 2016
election results through an economic
lens rich middle-class and poor we've
been analyzing it through educational
lenses and in so many ways but one of
the clearly growing divides in the
United States is that between rural
suburban and urban cities and in fact
Donald Trump many times talking about
inner cities and using the word urban
and talking about non-white groups
almost interchangeably in a way that was
actually a little bizarre but maybe
that's getting us a little way from what
we want to talk to you today how
important is this lens of the divide
between where people live in the u.s.
yeah no it's it's it's what a dramatic
situation that we're facing today I mean
as we've been reading from since the
election and happen until today there's
been a lot of articles that relate to
that situation is the urban rural abide
and I also want to emphasize that you
also did was a suburban by which I think
it's even more important than the other
two for the case of the election now on
one hand we have a situation where yes
there's a call for a network of shall I
say rebel cities or sanctuary cities
right now I think we have already around
35 I mean there's a series of CDs that
are already engaging in sanctuary spaces
and of course clearly as we know 35 of
the largest C's in the u.s. beat Trump
by a big margin 59% and and then you
have a situation where there's a
polarization happening which we've never
seen for a very long time perhaps it's
an it's the first time that we see a
polarization of such dimensions the big
you that we see or that I see on this
has to do with emphasizing that CDs
continued to be sort of like these
spaces where we harbors and kind of
progressive politics but at the same
time we continue to abandon and as we
have for many many years the rural and
the suburban spaces which are very much
codependent with urban centers right so
the situation today it's actually quite
unique and and we're battling on how to
deal with that with that um so one thing
that I think would be interesting to get
your thoughts on would be sort of a
which came first is in your analysis
does it appear as though if you grow up
in a rural area for example you are more
likely to end up being more politically
conservative and voting for Republican
candidates or is it that if you are
already predisposed based on parents or
whatever else to be conservative that
you ultimately find your way to more
rural areas do you have a sense of that
yeah there's a very long history on the
suburbanization of the United States and
I want to emphasize that McCarthy I mean
the lie behind McCarthyism was very much
engaged in the promotion of the
development of lennie town you know
which is considered to be one of the you
know first suburban towns in the United
States yeah the low lying around him
yeah and he argued to come to to
Congress that they needed a capitalist
mode of of basically of living visa
being what the Russians and other
socialist countries in Europe were
proposing which were more collective
forms of living his argument was that in
a sewer you have you can be divided in a
way that you don't need to rag with your
neighbors is better it's less of an
issue of organizing and the focus on
these would be of course consumption
right and many of other things and so
the ideology really played a very big
role in the definition of what's or it's
really an American is now so we can go
from there of course we can go to 19th
century and so on but I think in the
United States it's very telling that
that idea of individualism is very
tailored to the territorial sort of a
definition now on how people engage in
the daily lives it's less contact
right on the other hand you have there
in spaces right which is normally I mean
of course we call New York San
Francisco's very compact but in general
you have a much more daily experience of
the other right and therefore your your
sense of daily life becomes quite
adapted to the experience of the other
and most certainly understanding the
other position right in suburban
environments you have much less contact
with people and therefore it's an it's
an obvious you know result from this
when we look at cities to growing issues
and one I discussed recently there was a
very interesting article I think it was
in the Atlantic talking about the
increasing unaffordability of liberal
cities in the United States I'd love for
you to you could pick either or both of
these and sort of tell me which
direction you want to go in first
affordable housing in cities and or
zoning in big cities which of these do
you think is more important to sort of
think about in terms of how it relates
to politics and different populations
and how they're distributed in the
United States yeah I mean of course
targets I mean we want to extend to
these elections sort of topic I mean it
targets a lot of are the big issues
within Syria today I mean most cities
right now in the United States and large
cities are impossible actually to be
able to live in that I tell my friends
if you want to continue your city you
might want to be sure what's your salary
and your salary top analysis for your
sellers to be able to leave even a more
like decent you know life over here the
prices of houses rise and this has to do
a lot with the speculative factor that
cities have been 18 you know developers
in pushing there's this big discussion
today about that supply and demand will
serve a situation of like developers for
example continue building affordable
houses but we always argue that when the
man never works I mean never works ever
but especially in the housing issue
because housing is normally treated in
this economy as a commodity so it's not
a matter of supplying housing for those
that need it it's a matters
or the housing for the investors no for
those that want to speculate on the
housing and meantime those that need it
don't have enough housing to address it
and so most of the contemporary ways are
the limits on reaching affordability
which have to do with zoning or putting
a other programs like 421 a or some
other policies that have to do with
fiscal incentives to developers continue
to emphasize the idea that it's to make
as to promote speculation all of them
including Sony and so forth it seems to
me that we need a very radical
restructuring of how we think housing
especially on the context of CDs but
also as I want to say to want to
polarize you know the suburban and rural
areas which are also very dependent on
the prices here you can see for example
in C centers like New York you have
right now most of the rural areas
upstate now increasing in price has
making it even less affordable for those
that were thinking of moving forward now
or moving to a different area that is
more affordable so we have a ya a
conundrum and right now with the Ben
Carson in charge of all of these I think
we can just see an acceleration of all
these qualities especially because
they're going to be pushing it towards
more privatization and more the idea
that house needs a commodity and it's
not meant for people to live in it's
meant for as a currency right so to
accumulate when one of the areas in
which at least at face value it seems
that progressives might overlap with
president elect Donald Trump is on the
idea of significant infrastructure
spending now if we for a second put
aside that the specifics of how Donald
Trump would do the infrastructure
spending is is the same type of status
quo crony capitalism that we've seen for
a long time let's just temporarily
ignore that for our conversation if
there were to be significant
infrastructure spending done in cities
what in particular do you think could be
done to increase the amount of
affordable housing and/or deal with the
increasing lack of affordability in
these cities how could that money be
spent yeah I mean whether any any regime
if I should say I mean whether it would
be Clinton or Bernie or or in these case
on on Trump we would be facing with
infrastructure spending of course
you erase all the property values you
know if you build a decent park or this
is a bridge or more public
transportation systems clearly there's
gonna be a demand from those that
speculate on property or those that want
to move to a better place let's say that
it's more to their liking so in my
opinion and the opinion of several of my
peers I mean there's only one way to go
forward with this and this would be to
structure different policies that unable
different kinds of speculation and I
want to call it a specific type of
speculation which is a predatory form of
speculation which is that you know the
norm at this point you know you you buy
something for five hundred thousand one
year and then you sell it the next year
for a million which is crazy in New York
we have seen things that are just
unbelievable the rise of prices and the
way that these predatory speculators
operate so as long as we don't have
policies that break or that somehow
balance you know either through fiscal
incentives either to the promotion of
collected property which is the one that
I'm favored a lot Community Land
transformations which Bernie experienced
Bernie Sanders experienced a lot in
Vermont in and he was very engaged in
this which is forms of property that
cannot be speculated upon know that
basically you buy the house and then you
can sell the house just with
inflationary rates on top but not
anything extra and those type of housing
sort of schemes getting to that idea
that housing is right you know and it's
not something that we can trade upon in
a way that any normal commodity should
be done so in our principle I know it
sounds very radical but I there needs to
be a different laws that break or
policies the amount of speculation that
is going on and this is again
independent of if it's Trump or Clinton
or Bernie Sanders right these will
continue to happen incredibly important
issue and one that we're going to
continue following the growing
socio-political divide between rural
urban and suburban areas
Miguel thanks so much for talking to us
about this today thank you very much
David it was a pleasure initial